you're so beautiful
Thanks hi there jack nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey we're gonna talk
about the new live-action version of The
Lion King I would like to thank today's
video sponsor they are lovely Ridge
wallet flashy John yeah tell them about
it John
well the ridge makes these nifty
minimalist metal plated wallets they
come in aluminum titanium and carbon
fiber they're a great way to keep all
your stuff in order and they fit in a
front pocket or a shirt pocket a lot
better than sitting on a thick leather
bulky wallet and also I mean they don't
stop there they got these weatherproof
bags they got power banks yeah knives if
you need a knife yeah head on over to
our special link in the description box
get yourself a minimalist wallet of some
sort - and what's our promo code reject
nation that's our promo code that's rig
comm slash reject nation go there
support alright guys well I don't need
to go over the plot you've probably seen
the animated movie this is this point y
know how it all goes you know the story
I was really looking forward to this
film you know I'm not one of those
people who's anti shot-for-shot remake
with these Disney you know it's not
really a live-action film I would
consider this just you to believe it
wants you to believe it is it's the
whole point of it for the most part it's
it's all visual effects it's all CGI
it's animated and what they did here
what the movie was they essentially did
the same movie they change voice actors
except for one voice actor which is
James Earl Jones is Mufasa which I
understand why they didn't you know it's
James Earl Jones kind of hard to replace
the guy they did the same story they did
it in a different type of animation
format that's kind of how I viewed it
almost as if I was watching a like
YouTube fan film how we're a bunch of
creators got together to put together
the most experimental fan film which is
okay what if we did the Lion King with
new technologies new technology yeah
with a different kind of animation where
it looked very photorealistic that
question that people always posed with
these
action remakes I'm just gonna call it
that all right I want to get until the
semantics and technicalities of what
this really is that's what it's been
sort of pitched as to us right when I
was watching and I was thinking to
myself like well yeah what is the point
of this you know early on in the film
when they did the opening of it with the
circle of life moment it hit me why I
thought this would actually be a really
cool film honestly it didn't quite hit
me and even in the trailers what would
make this pretty special it was when
Rafiki picks up Simba I had the thought
of oh that's part of what's cool about
this looking realistic because this
would never happened and real life never
I mean one of these animals would ever
gather together these animals would not
get along none of this would happen you
know beyond like the whole voice stuff
it's never gonna happen in real life
yeah so it's pretty cool to see like the
most realistic take we can have if these
animals did get together and they react
to the light you know oh I see the point
of the experiment now the visuals like
get it out of the way as everyone has
been saying have been mind-blowing
they're fantastic it's beautiful to look
at beautiful to behold I'm hoping the
movie gets its the Oscar for visual
effects I just can't imagine another
movie out doing what they did here the
amount of times where I would get hold
out with the thought of man that looks
so real how do they do how they do
they've got a real line notice not again
never mind they can't be real because of
what they have it is one of those
strange experiences where it's not
necessarily bad that you got pulled out
but it is like such a feat that it's
hard not to think about there's times
where it doesn't always look a hundred
percent real but there are times we're
really done yeah and the the interesting
thing for me is that I think this is
obviously one of the most dazzling
elements of the movie it's one of the
most breathtaking and it's one of the
most impressive and I really like just
to give a little credit to John Favreau
one of the most unique things that the
visuals do other than bringing the story
to life embodying some of that nature
documentary type shooting after National
Geographic film yeah yeah and I really
liked those flourishes on the other hand
I do think it's interesting going over
from the traditional 2d animation
hand-drawn animation to this format
because it creates this kind of uncanny
valley I've never experienced before
because the thing is the way the action
plays out you know
is still pretty family-friendly so you
have all these very real looking things
behaving in ways they wouldn't and you
don't have a human to ground it we saw
this done in the Jungle Book
yes and that was really impressive and
it also had a human to ground it so you
don't have that kind of uncanny nacelle
the fantasy of it and I thought that
sometimes while impressive it would
break my suspension of disbelief or
something the way everything comes
together under the guise of being real
it's making this effort to be as real as
possible but the same time you're like
but this would never really happen
there's no like the ramifications of
violence just aren't what you're used to
and then when you're shooting stuff like
a nature documentary but it doesn't
behave that way there is like an uncanny
yes connect there yeah I will say though
in terms of like the voice acting in
here I think Seth Rogen and Billy
Eichner were the best parts of it for me
I definitely lost myself into the movie
when they were around yeah they brought
the most life they added something new
to it because I'm not anti shot-for-shot
remake with these films because I feel
for the most part these live-action
remakes have at least made the effort to
do something different to do something
new and have its own life have its own
personality be fresh and not just sit
there reminding me of the original you
know that's something I really like that
Aladdin actually pulled off pretty well
with this movie I gotta be honest I
think this movie is a crowd-pleaser our
crowd was hyped like it was endgame
people were cheering and clapping and
weeping my point with that is most of
those people I don't I didn't get the
impression their press or influencers or
whatever they were just people and man
they were like really living it up
loving it and I think too if you're
someone who's just like an animal lover
and loves those kind of nature
documentaries and stuff or how deep your
Lion King nostalgia roots are is just a
fan I really think you're gonna love it
honestly I do the thing for me
personally I kind of found the
experience a little Hollow I'm not gonna
lie it was it's it does almost nothing
different there's like tweaks and
dialogue there are some things that I
thought were slightly enhanced and in a
more defined way like one thing I was
thinking about in the car ride home was
the relationship between scar and Mufasa
how I really felt that scar felt robbed
from having the kingdom to his own
there's very little things other than it
was kind of like watching a weird
animated recreation play there's so much
in this movie that has a lot of TLC in
it there's so much care and time and
work put into bolstering the visuals and
different things and I feel like they
paid the least attention to accentuating
the story through all of this because
the weakest element to me is the
emotional dramatic story and it's weird
to say that because it's pretty much the
same thing the only time the movie
really touched me with hearts or life or
energy beyond what the score was doing
and how beautiful the visuals were was
when the comedians were probably riffing
because that's when there were fresh
character moments yeah um I'm all for
like the same beat sheet honestly you
know or and maybe adding like a scene or
two or whatever for most of the movie I
was just going this is like the exact
same movie a hundred percent the exact
same thing and you said it in the car it
does breathe better somehow as the
original anime oh the original animated
movie like that they do a lot of the
same there are certain like the
especially in the musical numbers where
they had to you know make it feel more
realistic so some songs were cut a
little shorter the way the the montages
and certain sequences like I just can't
wait to be king we're definitely
executed differently because of the fact
that it going for this more realistic
approach as realistic as possible for
this story right there are moments
though where I'm like well actually if
you if you mirrored like in the Stampede
moment you know with Mufasa and Simba's
caught in the Stampede I referenced in
the car ride how there's that shot where
Simba feels the Stampede coming and it
does this crash zoom on his face and you
see the horror and they completely don't
have that shot in here but they have
like a bunch of other same shot they
don't have that shot the way they went
into the Stampede I kind of felt like it
was a play-by-play of the animated movie
which meant that the breathing room did
it feel like it was a little bit rushed
at times and they were like doing all
the same notes but because it wasn't
really making the effort to have its own
personality or its own unique life other
than the imagery honestly ring a little
empty yeah it didn't really revel in the
emotion and the pacing felt very
mathematical to me yeah just feel like
they could have done especially for
Simba and all something to endear
further than just the originals it's
weird it's like I don't know how to
exactly quantum it's like I like it
because I love the animated movie and I
liked what they were experimenting with
here and it reminds me so much of the
animated movie he said I don't dislike
this movie I feel like there's some
people having really totally worth it I
think it's absolutely were seen and I do
think that it deserves the Oscar for the
visual effects and I do think it's a
definite crowd-pleaser if I were to
describe my experience it gave me
exactly what I expected
literally nothing exactly and I could
have used a little more at the same time
it why I say play because almost all the
dialogue other than when comedians are
riffing are pretty much the same it's
interesting hearing James Earl Jones
return and doing the same dialogue just
different delivery and that's where the
play reference comes into mind when
you're like oh yeah I've seen another
actor do that without enough of its own
flavor or Sensibility it's almost too
reverent to the original to me yeah I
thought they could have done something
more to make it their own beyond safe
translation of something yeah you know
it's like the music's all great the
score is all great but even the music
for me I thought the music and the score
were great I thought the score did the
heavy lifting for a lot of the emotion
you brought this point up about some of
the voice performances whereas you don't
have the cartoon style emotion you have
the voice work I'm so aware they're in a
recording booth you could feel how
animated their voices are but because
they're going for photorealistic oh the
animals their expression is not matching
with the voice yeah and then multiply
that by three when it becomes a musical
number for me yeah I was impressed in
appreciating them but still in a moment
where I was pulled out and going ah
there's something not quite coalescing
and for a movie that would the whole
point was to immerse you into a more
realistic take in the Lion King I never
actually felt immersed into it I know
that this is just our opinion because I
know plenty of you I saw it I heard it
too heard the tears in the crowd I heard
saw it all I heard the laughter the
consistent applause and for some reason
house
and I don't even think they had to make
it different I think they just needed to
find a different balance of tone or of
scope well world or something like that
well the thing is this this script and
the what they did with the animated
movie was it's all fine-tuned for the
animation style yeah and they didn't
seem to try to really fine-tune or tweak
all that mother's like little little
tiny things that could remember that or
this is kind of different this is
slightly different
oh they executed this a little different
yeah like the best part of the born of
the voices is James Earl Jones mom like
yeah and I mean there's still say if
you're gonna watch this watch on the big
screen because I feel like this is the
kind of movie critics would be lower on
it and audiences will really love it
that's that's just a vibe I guess I'm
okay with that I don't hate this movie
by any stretch I'm just more like no I
my opinion my feelings walking out was
like I think it's really beautiful I
liked it I wish I loved it every element
of this movie works and sometimes they
all merge coalescent Lee to make a
really moving piece but the rest of the
time they kind of come apart a little
bit yeah and you can feel the scenes and
because it was exactly the same just it
felt less energetic because the
animation brings so much life and then
when you're doing the exact script from
the animation and you're going for more
realism there's naturally less energy
times a little bit bored whatever
weirdly after all that I would still say
goes yeah I would still say like go
watch it's worth weird thing to say
after like being like yeah I found a
little hollow but I would still say go
watch it yeah to crib from some double
toast I still think it's like a
full-price watch okay see the lankey
next one you want them to good yeah you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell give a
lookout for more reviews from us and
thanks for Ridge wallet you guys are
great